ladies and gentlemen my name is saya
Daniels and I am permanent secretary of
the Swedish Academy I have a very
pleasant task this evening and it is to
introduce our writer the Nobel Prize
laureate of 2017 mr. Kazuo Ishiguro was
sitting here in front of me and let me
say how great it's been for the Swedish
Academy all the members of the Swedish
Academy to discuss your novels and your
great short stories it's taught us a
great deal and we're extremely pleased
that you want to be here with us today
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming
kasev oh you should go
[Applause]
the doors that Zora Daniels and I came
through just now over there I am told
are only open twice every year once when
the Permanent Secretary of the Swedish
Academy announces the winner of the
Nobel Prize and the second time when the
literature laureate comes in to deliver
the lecture so I feel really honored to
be only one of two people to come
through this door this year I'm now
wondering when I leave if if I try to go
out the same way I'll find the doors
locked and so I'm not quite sure how I
get out of here but um but it's one but
it's a terrific wonderful honor to be
here and thank you all for coming I know
some of you have come a long way if
you'd come across me in the autumn of
1979 you might have had some difficulty
placing me socially and even racially I
was then 24 years old my features would
have looked Japanese but unlike most
Japanese men seen in Britain in those
days I had hair down to my shoulders and
a drooping bandit style mustache the
only accent discernible in my speech was
that as someone brought up in the
southern counties of England inflected
at times by the language already dated
vernacular of the hippie era if we'd got
talking we might have discussed the
total footballers of Holland or Bob
Dylan's latest album or perhaps the year
I just spent working with homeless
people in London had you mentioned Japan
asked me about its culture you might
even have detected a trace of impatience
into my manner as I declared my
ignorance on the grounds that I hadn't
set foot in that country
not even for a Holi
day since leaving it at the age of five
that autumn I'd arrived with a rucksack
a guitar and a portable typewriter in
Buxton Norfolk a small English village
with an old water mill and flat farm
fields all around it I'd come to this
place because I'd been accepted on a
one-year postgraduate creative writing
course at the University of East Anglia
the university was ten miles away in the
Cathedral town of Norwich but I had no
car and my only way of getting there was
by means of a bus service that operated
just once in the morning once at
lunchtime and once in the evening but
this I was soon to discover was no great
hardship I was rarely required at the
university more than twice a week I'd
rented a room in a small house owned by
a man in his 30s his wife had just left
him no doubt for him the house was
filled with the ghosts of his wrecked
dreams or perhaps he just wanted to
avoid me in any case I didn't set eyes
on him for days on end in other words
after the frenetic life I'd been leading
in London here I was faced with an
unusual amount of quiet and solitude in
which to transform myself into a writer
in fact my little room was not unlike
the classic writers garret the ceilings
sloped claustrophobic Lee though if I
stood on tiptoes I had a view from one
of my windows of ploughed fields
stretching away into the distance there
was a small table the surface of which
my typewriter and the desk lamp took up
almost entirely on the floor instead of
a bed there was a large rectangular
piece of industrial foam that were
caused me to sweat in my sleep even
during the bitterly cold Norfolk nights
it was in this room that I carefully
examined the two short stories I'd
written over the summer
wondering if they were good enough to
submit to my new classmates we were I
knew a class of six meeting once every
two weeks at that point in my life I'd
written little else of notes in the way
of prose fiction having earned my place
on the course with a radio play rejected
by the BBC in fact having previously
made firm plans to become a rock star by
the time I was 20 my literary ambitions
had only recently made themselves known
to me the two stories I was now
scrutinizing had been written in
something of a panic in response to the
news that I've been accepted on the
University course one was about a
macabre suicide pact the other about
street fights in Scotland where I'd
spent some time as a community worker
they were not so good I started another
story about an adolescent who poisons
his cat set like the others in
present-day Britain then one night
during my third or fourth week in that
little room I found myself writing with
a new and urgent intensity about Japan
about Nagasaki the city of my birth
during the last days of the Second World
War this I should point out came as
something of a surprise to me today the
pervading atmosphere is such that it's
virtually an instinct for an aspiring
young writer with mixed cultural
heritage to explore his roots in his
work but that was far from the case then
we were still a few years away from the
explosion of multicultural literature in
Britain Salman Rushdie was an unknown
with one out of print novel asked to
name the leading young British novelist
of the day people might have mentioned
Margaret drabble of older writers Iris
Murdoch
Kingsley Amos William Golding Anthony
Burgess John Fowles foreigners like
Gabriel Garcia Marquez Milan Kundera or
Boris
but read only in tiny numbers their
names meaningless even to keen readers
such was the literary climate of the day
that when I finished that first Japanese
story for all my sense of having
discovered an important new direction
I began immediately to wonder if this
departure shouldn't be viewed as a
self-indulgence if I shouldn't quickly
return to more normal subject matter it
was only after considerable hesitation
that I began to show the story around
and I remained to this day profoundly
grateful to my fellow students my tutors
Malcolm Bradbury and Angela Carter and
to the novelist Paul Bailey that year
the university's writer in residence for
their determinedly encouraging response
had they been less positive I would
probably never again have written about
Japan as it was I returned to my room
and wrote and wrote throughout the
winter of 1979 1980 and weds into the
spring
I spoke to virtually no one aside from
the other five students in my class the
village grocer from whom I bought the
breakfast cereals and lamb kidneys on
which I existed and my girlfriend Lorna
today my wife who had come to visit me
every second weekend it wasn't a
balanced life but in those four or five
months I managed to complete one half of
my first novel a pair of you of hills
set also in Nagasaki in the years of
recovery after the dropping of the
atomic bomb I can remember occasionally
during this period tinkering with some
ideas for short stories not set in Japan
only to find my interest waning rapidly
those months but crucial for me insofar
as without them I probably never have
become a writer since then I've often
looked back and asked what was going on
with me what was all this peculiar
energy my conclusion has been that just
that that
in my life I'd become engaged in an
urgent act of preservation to explain
this I'll need to go back a little I had
come to England aged five with my
parents and sister in April 1962 the
town of Guildford Surrey in the affluent
stockbroker belt 30 miles south of
London my father was a research
scientist an oceanographer who'd come to
work for the British government the
Machine he went on to invent
incidentally is today part of the
permanent collection at the Science
Museum in London the photographs taken
shortly after our arrival show an
England from a vanished era men wear
wooden v-neck put overs with ties cars
still have running boards and a spare
wheel on the back the Beatles the sexual
revolution student protests
multiculturalism were all around the
corner but it's hard to believe the
England our family first encountered
even suspected it to meet a foreigner
from France or Italy was remarkable
enough never mind one from Japan our
family lived in a quarter sack of twelve
houses just where the paved roads ended
and the countryside began it was less
than a five-minute stroll to the local
farm and the laying down which rows of
cows trudged back and forth between
fields milk was delivered by horse and
cart a common sight I remember vividly
from my first days in England was that
of hedgehogs
the cute spiky nocturnal creatures there
numerous in that country squashed by car
wheels during the night left in the
morning dew' tucked neatly by the
roadside awaiting collection by the
refugees men all our neighbours went to
church and I'm well and when I went to
play with our children I noticed they
said a small prayer before eating
I attended Sunday school and before long
was singing in the church choir becoming
aged 10 the first Japanese head
chorister seen in Guildford I went to
the local primary school where I was the
only non English child quite possibly in
the entire history of that school and
from when I was 11 I traveled by train
to my grammar school in a neighboring
town sharing the carriage each morning
with ranks of men in pinstripe suits and
bowler hats on their way to their
offices in London by this stage I had
become thoroughly trained in the manners
expected of middle-class boys in those
days when visiting a friend's house I
knew I should stand to attention the
instant an adult wandered into the room
I learned that during a meal I had to
ask permission before getting down from
the table as the only foreign boy in the
neighborhood a kind of local Fame
followed me around other children knew
who I was before I met them adults who
were total strangers to me sometimes
addressed me by name in the street or in
the local store when I looked back to
this period and remember that it was
less than 20 years from the end of a
World War in which the Japanese had been
bitter enemies I'm amazed by the
openness and instinctive generosity with
which our family was accepted by this
ordinary English community the affection
respect and curiosity I retained to this
day for that generation of Britons who
came through the Second World War and
built a remarkable new welfare state in
its aftermath derived significantly from
my personal experiences from those years
but all this time I was leading another
life at home with my Japanese parents at
home there were different rules
different expectations a different
language by parents original intention
had been that we returned to Japan after
a year perhaps two if
for our first 11 years in England we
were in a perpetual state of going back
next year as a result my parents outlook
remained at of visitors not of
immigrants they'd often exchange
observations about the curious customs
of the natives without feeling any onus
to adopt them and for a long time the
assumption remained that I would return
to live my adult life in Japan and
efforts were made to keep up the
Japanese side of my education each vanta
parcel arrived from Japan containing the
previous month's comics magazines
educational digests all of which I
devoured eagerly these parcels stopped
arriving sometime in my teens
perhaps after my grandfather's death but
my parents talked of old friends
relatives episodes from their lives in
Japan all kept up a steady supply of
images and impressions and then I always
had my own store of memories
surprisingly vast and clear of my
grandparents or favorite toys I'd left
behind the traditional Japanese house
we'd lived in which I can even today
reconstruct in my mind room by room my
kindergarten the local tram stop the
fierce dog that death by the bridge the
chair in the barber's shop specially
adapted for small boys with a car
steering wheel fixed in front of the big
mirror what all this amounted to was
that as I was growing up long before I'd
ever thought to create fictional worlds
in prose I was busily constructing in my
mind a rich the detailed place called
Japan a place to which I in some way
belonged from which I drew a certain
sense of my identity and my confidence
the fact that I'd never physically
returned to Japan during that time only
served to make my own vision of the
country more vivid and personal hence
the need for preservation for by the
time I reached my mid-20s
though I never clearly articulated this
at the time I was coming to realize
certain things I was starting to accept
that my Japan perhaps did it much
correspond to any place I could go to on
the plane that the way of life of which
my parents talked that I remembered from
my early childhood had largely vanished
during the 1960s and 1970s that in any
case the Japan that existed in my head
might always have been an emotional
construct put together by a child out of
memory imagination and speculation and
perhaps most significantly I had come to
realize that with each year I grew older
this Japan of mine this precious place
I'd grown up with was getting fainter
and fainter I'm now sure that it was
this feeling that my Japan was unique
and at the same time terribly fragile
something not open to verification from
outside that drove me on to work in that
small room in Norfolk what I was doing
was getting down on paper that world's
special colors morays etiquettes its
dignity its shortcomings everything I'd
ever thought about the place before they
faded forever from my mind it was my
wish to rebuild my Japan in fiction to
make it safe so that I could thereafter
point to a book and say yes there's my
Japan inside there
spring 1983 three and a half years later
Lorna and I were now in London lodging
in two rooms at the top of a tall narrow
house which itself stood on a hill at
one of the highest points of the city
there was a television mast nearby and
when we tried to listen to records on
our turntable ghostly broadcasting
voices would intermittently invade our
speakers our living room had no sofa or
armchair but two mattresses on the floor
covered with cushions there was also a
large table on which I wrote during the
day and where we had dinner at night it
wasn't luxurious but we liked living
there I'd published my first novel the
year before and I'd also written a
screenplay for a short film soon to be
broadcast on British television I'd been
for a time reasonably proud of my first
novel but by that spring a niggling
sense of dissatisfaction had set in here
was the problem
my first novel and my first TV
screenplay were too similar not in
subject matter but in method and style
the more I looked at it the more my
novel resembled a screenplay dialogue +
directions this was okay up to a point
but my wish now was to write fiction
that could work properly only on the
page why write a novel if it was going
to offer more or less the same
experience someone could get by turning
on the television how could written
fiction hope to survive against the
might of cinema and television if it
didn't offer something unique something
the other forms couldn't do around this
time I came down with a virus and spent
a few days in bed when I came out of the
worst of it and I didn't feel like
sleeping all the time I discovered that
the heavy object whose presence emits my
bed clothes had been annoying me for
some time
was in fact a copy of the first
volume of marcel proust remembrance of
things past as the title was then
translated there it was so I started to
read it my still fevered condition was
perhaps a factor but I became completely
riveted by the overture and compre
sections I read them over and over quite
aside from the sheer beauty of these
passages I became thrilled by the means
by which Proust got one episode to lead
into the next the ordering of events and
scenes didn't seem to follow the usual
demands of chronology nor those of a
linear plot instead tangential thought
associations or the vagaries of memory
seemed to move the writing from one
episode to the next sometimes I found
myself wondering why had these two
seemingly unrelated moments been placed
side by side in the narrator's mind I
could suddenly see an exciting freer way
of composing my second novel one that
could produce richness on the page and
offer inner movements impossible to
capture on any screen if I could go from
one passage to the next according to the
narrator's thought associations and
drifting memories I could compose in
something like the way an abstract
painter might choose to place shapes and
colors around the canvas I could place a
scene from two days ago right beside one
from 20 years earlier and ask the reader
to ponder the relationship between the
two in such a way I began to think I
might suggest the many layers of
self-deception and denial that shrouded
any person's view of their own self and
of their past March 1988 I was 33 years
old we now had a sofa and I was lying
across it listening to a Tom Waits album
the previous year Laura and I had bought
our own house in an unfashionable
but pleasant part of South London and in
this house for the first time I had my
own study it was small and didn't have a
door but I was thrilled to spread my
papers around and not have to clear them
away at the end of each day and in that
study or so I believed I just finished
my third novel it was my first not to
have a Japanese setting by personal
Japan having been made less fragile by
the writing of my previous novels in
fact my new book to be called the
remains of the day seemed English in the
extreme though not I hoped in the manner
of many British authors of the older
generation I'd been careful not to
assume as I felt many of them did that
my readers were all English with native
familiarity of English nuances and
preoccupations by then writers like
Salman Rushdie and VS Naipaul
had forged the way for a more
international outward looking British
literature one that didn't claim any
centrality or automatic importance for
Britain their writing was post-colonial
in the widest sense I wanted like them
to write international fiction that
could easily cross cultural and
linguistic boundaries even while writing
a story set in what seemed a peculiarly
English world my version of England
would be a kind of mythical one whose
outlines I believed were already present
in the imaginations of many people
around the world including those who had
never visited the country the story I
just finished was about an English
Butler who realizes too late in his life
that he has lived his life by the wrong
values that he's given his best years to
serving a Nazi sympathizer that by
failing to take moral and political
responsibility for his life he has in
some profound sense wasted that life and
more that in his bid to become the
perfect servant he has forbidden himself
to love or be loved by
the one woman he cares for I read
through my manuscript several times and
I've been recently satisfied still there
was a niggling feeling that something
was missing then as I say there I was in
our house one evening on our sofa
listening to Tom Waits
and Tom Waits began to sing a song
called Ruby's arms perhaps some of you
know it I even thought about singing
singing it to you at this point but I've
changed my mind
it's a ballad about a man possibly a
soldier leaving his lover asleep in bed
it's the early morning he goes down the
road gets on the train nothing unusual
in that but the song is delivered in the
voice of a gruff American hobo utter the
unaccustomed to revealing his deeper
emotions and there comes a moment midway
through the song when the singer tells
us that his heart is breaking the moment
is almost unbearably moving because of
the tension between the sentiment itself
and the huge resistance that's obviously
been overcome to declare it Tom Waits
sings the line with cathartic
magnificence and you feel a lifetime of
tough-guy stoicism crumbling in the face
of overwhelming sadness as I listened to
Tom Waits I realize what I still have to
do I done thinking Lea made a decision
somewhere way back but my English Butler
would maintain his emotional defenses
that he'd managed to hide behind them
from himself and his reader to the very
end now I saw I had to reverse that
decision just for one moment towards the
end of my story a moment I'd have to
choose carefully I had to make his armor
crack I had to allow a vast and tragic
yearning to be glimpsed underneath I
should say here that I have on a number
of other occasions
learned crucial lessons from the voices
of singers I refer her I refer here des
to the lyrics being sung and more to the
actual singing as we know a human voice
in song is capable of expressing an
unfathomably complex blend of feelings
over the years specific aspects of my
writing have been influenced by amongst
others Bob Dylan Nina Simone Emmylou
Harris Ray Charles Bruce Springsteen
Gillian Welch and my friend and
collaborator Staci Kent catching
something in their voices I've said to
myself oh yes that's it that's what I
need to capture in that scene something
very close to that it's it's often an
emotion I can't quite put into words but
there it is in the singer's voice and
now I've been given something to aim for
in October 1999 I was invited by the
German poet Kristoff high blur on behalf
of the International alphabets committee
to spend a few days visiting the former
concentration camp my accommodation was
at the Auschwitz youth meeting center on
the road between the first Alfred's camp
and the BIR Canal death camp two miles
away I was shown around these sites and
met informally three survivors I felt
I'd come close geographically at least
to the heart of the dark force under
whose shadow my generation had grown up
at Birkenau on the wet afternoon I stood
before the rubble remains of the gas
chambers now strangely neglected and
unattended left much as the Germans had
left them after blowing them up and
fleeing the Red Army they were now just
damp broken slabs exposed to the harsh
Polish climate deteriorating year by
year my hosts talked about their dilemma
should these remains be
affected should perspex domes be built
to cover them over to preserve them for
the eyes of succeeding generations or
should they be allowed slowly and
naturally to rot away to nothing it
seemed to me a powerful metaphor for a
larger dilemma how was such memories to
be preserved with the glass domes
transformed these relics of evil and
suffering entertainment what should we
choose to remember when is it better to
forget and move on I was 44 years old
until then I'd considered the second
world war its horrors and its triumph as
belonging to my parents generation but
now it occurred to me that before too
long many who had witnessed those huge
events at firsthand would not be alive
and what then did the burden of
remembering fall to my own generation we
hadn't experienced the war years but
we'd at least been brought up by parents
whose lives have been indelibly shaped
by them did I now as a public teller of
stories have a duty I did achieve been
unaware of a duty to pass on as best I
could these memories and lessons from
our parents generation to the one after
our own and it's a while later I was
speaking before an audience in Tokyo and
a question from the floor asked as is
common what I might work on next
more specifically the questioner pointed
out that my books had often concerned
individuals who had lived through times
of great social and political upheaval
and who then looked back over their
lives and struggled to come to terms
were their darker more shameful memories
with my future books she asked continue
to cover a similar territory I found
myself giving a quite unprepared answer
yes I said I'd often written about such
individuals
struggling between forgetting and
remembering but in the future what I
really wish to do was to write a story
about how a nation or a community face
these same questions does a nation
remember and forget in much the same way
as an individual does or are there
important differences what exactly are
the memories of a nation where are they
kept how are they shaped and controlled
are there times when forgetting is the
only way to stop cycles of violence or
to stop a society disintegrating into
chaos or war on the other hand can
stable free nations really be built on
foundations of willful amnesia and
frustrated justice I heard myself
telling the questioner that I wanted to
find a way to write about these things
but that for the moment unfortunately I
couldn't think of how I do it one
evening in early 2001 in the darkened
front room of our house in North London
where we were by then living lorna and i
began to watch on a reasonable quality
VHS tape a 1934 Howard Hawks film called
20th century the film's title we soon
discovered referred not to the century
we then just left behind but to a famous
luxury train of the era connecting New
York and Chicago as some of you will
know the film is a fast paced comedy set
largely on the train concerning a
Broadway producer who with increasing
desperation tries to prevent his leading
actress going to Hollywood to become a
movie star the film is built around the
huge comic performance by John Barrymore
one of the great actors of his day his
facial expressions his gestures almost
every line he utters come layered with
ironies contradictions the grotesque
grease of a man drowning in
egocentrism and self-dramatization it is
in many ways a brilliant performance yet
as the film continued to unfold
I found myself curiously uninvolved this
puzzled me at first I usually like to
bury more and was a big enthusiast for
Howard horses other films from this era
such as his girl Friday or only Angels
have wings then around the film's one
hour mark a simple striking idea came
into my head the reason why so many
vivid undeniably convincing characters
in novels films in place so often failed
to touch me was because these characters
didn't connect in any to any of the
other characters in an interesting human
relationship and immediately this next
thought came regarding my work what if I
stopped worrying about my characters and
worried instead about my relationships
as a train rattled father West and John
Barrymore became ever more hysterical
I thought about Ian foresters famous
distinction between three dimensional
and two dimensional characters a
character in a story became
three-dimensional he'd said by virtue of
the fact that they surprised us
convincingly it was in so doing that
they became rounded but what I now
wondered if a character was
three-dimensional while all his or her
relationships were not elsewhere in that
same lecture series Forrester had used a
humorous image of extracting the story
line out of a novel with a pair of
forceps and holding it up like a
wriggling worm for examination under the
light couldn't I perform a similar
exercise and hold up to the light the
very various relationships that
crisscross any story could I do this to
my own work two stories I had completed
and once I was planning
I could look at say this mentor pupil
relationship does it say something
insightful and fresh well now that I was
staring at it does it become obvious
it's a tired stereotype identical to
those found in hundreds of mediocre
stories or this relationship between two
competitive friends is it dynamic does
it have emotional resonance does it
evolve does it surprise convincingly is
it three-dimensional I suddenly felt I
understood better why in the past
various aspects of my work had failed
despite my applying desperate remedies
the thought came to me as I continued to
stare at John Barrymore but all good
stories
nevermind how radical or traditional
their mode of telling had to contain
relationships that are important to us
that move us amuse us anger us surprise
us perhaps in future if I attended more
to my relationships my characters will
take care of themselves it occurs to me
as I say this that I might be making a
point here that has always been plainly
obvious to you but what I can say is
that it was an idea that came to me
surprisingly late in my writing life and
I see it now as a turning point
comparable with the others I've been
describing to you today from then on I
began to build my stories in a different
way when writing my novel never let me
go for instance I set off from the start
by thinking about its central
relationships triangle and then the
other relationships that found out from
it important turning points in the
writers career perhaps in many kinds of
career and I Cleese often they are small
scruffy moments they are quiet private
sparks of revelation they don't come
often and when they do
they may well come without fanfare
unendorsed by mentors or colleagues they
must often compete for attention with
louder seemingly more urgent demands
sometimes what they reveal may go
against the grain of pervading wisdom
but when they come it's important to be
able to recognize them for what they are
or they'll slip through your hands I've
been emphasizing here the small and the
private because essentially that's what
my work is about one person writing in a
quiet room trying to connect with
another person reading in another quiet
or maybe not so quiet room stories can
entertain sometimes teach or argue a
point but for me the essential thing is
that they communicate feelings that they
appeal to what we share as human beings
across our borders and divides there are
large glamorous industries around
stories the book industry the movie
industry the television industry the
theater industry but in the end stories
are about one person saying to another
this is the way it feels to me can you
understand what I'm saying
does it also feel this way to you so we
come to the present I woke up recently
to the realization I've been living for
some years in a bubble that I'd fail to
notice the frustration and anxieties of
many people around me I saw that my
world a civilized stimulating place
filled with ironic liberal minded people
was in fact much smaller than I'd ever
imagined 2016 a year of surprising and
for me depressing political events in
Europe and in America and her sickening
acts of terrorism all around the globe
forced me to acknowledge that the
unstoppable advance of liberal humanist
values I taken for granted since
childhood may have been an illusion I am
part of a generation inclined to
optimism and why not we watched our
elders successfully transform Europe
from a place of totalitarian regimes
genocide and historically unprecedented
carnage to a much envied region of
liberal democracies living in near
borderless friendship we watched the old
colonial empires crumble around the
world together with the reprehensible
assumptions that underpin them we saw
significant progress in feminism gay
rights and the battles on several fronts
against racism we grew up against a
backdrop of the great clash ideological
and military between capitalism and
communism and witnessed what many of us
believe to be a happy conclusion but now
looking back the era since the fall of
the Berlin Wall seems like one of
complacency of opportunities lost
enormous inequalities of wealth and
opportunity have been allowed to grow
between nations and within nations in
particular the disastrous invasion of
Iraq in 2003 and the long years of
austerity policies imposed on ordinary
people following the scandalous economic
crash of 2008 have brought us to a
present in which far-right ideologies
and tribal nationalisms proliferate
racism in its traditional forms and in
its modernised better marketed versions
is once again on the rise stirring
beneath our civilised streets like a
buried monster awakening for the moment
we seem to lack any progressive cause to
unite us instead even in the wealthy
democracies of the West we are
fracturing into rival camps
from which to compete bitterly for
resources or power and around the corner
or have we already turned this corner
like the challenges posed by the
stunning breakthroughs in science
technology and medicine new genetic
technologies such as the gene editing
technique CRISPR and advances in
artificial intelligence and robotics
will bring us amazing life-saving
benefits but may also create savage
meritocracies that resemble apartheid
and massive unemployment including to
those in the current professional elites
so here I am a man in my 60s rubbing my
eyes and trying to discern the outlines
out there in the mist
to this world I didn't suspect even
existed until yesterday can I a tired
author from an intellectually tired
generation now find the energy to look
at this unfamiliar place do I have
something left that might help to
provide perspective to bring emotional
layers to the arguments fights and Wars
that will come a society struggle to
adjust to huge changes I'd have to carry
on and do the best I can but because I
still believe that literature is
important and will be particularly so as
we cross this difficult terrain but I'll
be looking to the writers from the
younger generations to inspire and lead
us this is their era and they will have
the knowledge and instinct about it that
I will lack in the worlds of books
cinema TV and theater I see today
adventurous exciting tannins
women and men in their 40s 30s and 20s
so I am optimistic why shouldn't I be
but let me finish by making an appeal if
you like my nobel appeal
it's hard to put the whole world to
rights but let us at least think about
how we can prepare our own small corner
of it this corner of literature where we
read write publish recommend denounce
and give awards to books if we are to
play an important role in this uncertain
future if we are to get the best from
the writers of today and tomorrow I
believe we must become more diverse I
mean this in two particular senses
firstly we must white in our common
literary world to include many more
voices from beyond our comfort zones of
the elite first world cultures we must
search more energetically to discover
the gems from what remain today
unknown literary cultures whether the
writers live in faraway countries or
within our own communities second we
must take great care not to set too
narrowly or conservatively our
definitions of what constitutes good
literature the next generation will come
with all sorts of new sometimes
bewildering ways to tell important and
wonderful stories we must keep our minds
open to them especially regarding genre
and form so that we can nurture and
celebrate the best of them in a time of
dangerously increasing division we must
listen good writing and good reading
will break down barriers we may even
find a new idea a great humane vision
around which to rally to the Swedish
Academy the Noble Foundation and to the
people of Sweden who down the years have
made a Nobel Prize a shining symbol for
the good
we humans strive for I give my thanks
[Applause]
you